volcanoes are one of the deadliest and
most dangerous things we have on our
planet luckily most of them are dormant
and not able to harm us until
now we're going to look at what would
happen if these super volcano suddenly
erupted but that's not all we're also
going to check out what would happen if
one of the biggest volcanoes on Earth
decided to explode and then we'll
explore what happens after the volcanoes
erupt we'll show you what happens during
a volcanic
apocalypse this is one of the largest
super volcanoes in the world and now
it's beginning a massive
eruption but that's not all at this
moment every single super volcano is
exploding all around the world how many
super volcanoes would be
erupting What would it be like to
witness so many
eruptions and would this be the end of
Life as We Know
It This is what if and here's what would
happen if all super volcanoes blew up
tomorrow before we get ready to rumble
let's just get down to what's so super
about a super
volcano these things aren't just big
buckets of lava and Ash they're defined
by their colossal
huge
calderas these massive cauldron likee
depressions can span distances as large
as cities like Los Angeles New Delhi and
Singapore and when some of these super
volcanoes erupt they'll spew enough Rock
and Ash to cover entire countries in
debris so if they all went off at the
same time would you have anywhere safe
to go our super volcano chain reaction
begins in one of California's most
beloved national parks Yellowstone known
for its breathtaking geysers this whole
place sits on top of a massive super
volcano that could blow at any moment
this super volcano would explode with a
force about 2500 times more powerful
than the eruption of Mount St Helens in
1980 the sheer explosive power of this
would be equivalent to nearly one4 of a
million megatons of
TNT and plug your ears because this
eruption would be loud enough to be
heard across several States Ash would
blanket The Horizon and sadly most of
the National Park's Wildlife will die in
the fiery eruption or its
aftermath now before the dust begins to
settle on Yellowstone another eruption
will rock the west coast of the United
States this time the Long Valley called
would wake up from its
760,000 years Slumber that ancient
eruption was so powerful that it created
the Caldera that still exists today that
is to say it created the one that
existed up until a few minutes ago over
1,000 cubic kilm of debris would burst
out of the volcano sending an
unfathomable amount of Ash and lava into
the air next far across the Pacific
Mount Toba in Indonesia would detonate
with a deafening Roar Tropical Paradise
would turn into
pandemonium and millions of people live
close to this volcano so the death toll
from the eruption would be devastating
people all around the world would be
breathing in thick hot volcanic ash
without a heavy protective mask this
stuff would cause you to choke and you'd
be unable to breathe but this isn't the
first time that something like this has
happened the last time Toba erupted
74,000 years ago it was one of the most
powerful blasts in Earth's history the
vast amounts of material it ejected into
the atmosphere caused a so-called
volcanic winter blocking out the Sun and
leading to a significant drop in global
temperatures for the next several years
to round out our look at the chain
reaction of super volcanic eruptions
let's return close to the scene of one
of history's most infamous
eruptions Mount
Vesuvius its super volcanic neighbor the
compy flra would erupt and plunge the
Bay of Naples into even more
chaos 2,000 years ago vus wiped the city
of Pompei off the map today this super
volcano would threaten the lives of more
than 2 million people living in the
metropolitan area of Naples and if the
epicenter of this this eruption was
underwater well your Italian Beach
vacation would be ruined by tsunamis as
tall as 30 m heading right toward you
now these wouldn't be the only eruptions
happening around the world but already
the consequences would be
disastrous cities would be plunged Into
Darkness airports would ground flights
all over the world even just finding
breathable air would be a challenge the
chaos and destruction brought on by all
these eruptions would make millions of
people homeless and the numbers would
continue to grow as the effects of a
volcanic winter settle in with all the
volcanic material in the air our
atmosphere would be filled with sulfuric
acid blocking out the sun crops would
die decimating Food Supplies and leading
to mass extinctions of animal species
and just like in the aftermath of Mount
toba's ancient eruption global
temperatures would drop for several
years the one bright spot in this
literally dark situation would be that
this would significantly reverse the
effects of human impacted global warming
for a while and there would be hope that
in the aftermath civilization might join
together to figure out ways to keep life
going now let's take a deeper look and
see what would happen if the catoa
volcano erupted on the islands of
Indonesia a geological Beast is
Awakening kakato TOA is about to
blow
again how would you know this day was
coming how could this eruption make you
deaf and why could it be a good thing
for our
planet this is what if and here's what
would happen if kakato TOA erupted today
it's August
1883 in Indonesia and one of the most
catastrophic natural events in recorded
history has just occurred Krakatoa a
volcano on the island of rakar has
erupted violently sending enormous
amounts of gas and Ash High into the air
the explosion was so energetic that its
sound traveled a distance about the
width of the United
States
wow even though this volcanic island was
uninhabited at the time the devastating
aftermath of the eruption led to a death
toll as high as
36,000 people and that's not all it also
caused a little climate
change so if Krakatoa were to erupt
today would it be game over for
Humanity before jumping right into the
heart of this volcanic disaster scenario
there's one important detail you need to
know following its eruption in 1883 a
large part of the katoa volcano
collapsed into the sea it kept erupting
underwater and that allowed the volcano
to climb back out of the ocean but when
katoa erupted back then it was twice as
tall as it is today for today's katoa to
be extremely dangerous it would have to
return to its original
size so let's imagine a scenario where
the 1883 eruption never happened and
this volcano would be a ticking Time
Bomb ready to
blow if you lived in Indonesia's Capital
Jakarta you'd be among the first to
notice that something was wrong for
months you'd be hearing strange dull
booming noises followed by your doors
and windows violently
rattling these booms would be the result
of eruptions below the surface of the
Indian Ocean in the days after these
booms kakaa would start to blow up small
amounts of Ash would rain down as far
away as Southern India or
Thailand closer to ricotta Island where
you could see katoa large vault volumes
of steam and smoke would be rising from
its peak into the atmosphere over the
next few weeks massive amounts of
volcanic glass and molten rock would be
ejected this rock material would blanket
parts of the ocean surface around the
island and that would just be the
beginning of the disruption to the
fishing industry shipping lanes and to
all life forms in the coastal
ecosystem eventually that Tower of steam
smoke and Rocky material would get huge
the volcano would violently spew gas and
Ash as high up as 25 km into the
air yeah impressive but this portal to
the underworld is saving its Big Show
for
tomorrow the next day this Beast would
explode with so much energy that its
sound waves would Circle The Globe four
times and while not everyone on Earth
would hear the noise you could catch it
in
Australia yeah even 160 km away the
explosion would sound louder than a jet
engine hopefully you won't be any closer
than that because if you were too close
the bang would instantly rupture your
eardrums following the explosion the
surrounding regions would be plunged
Into
Darkness that's because all the volcanic
Ash that katoa spit out into the sky
would be blocking the sunlight for the
next 3
days but the worst would be yet to
come this massive explosion would cause
the volcano to collapse large parts of
Krakatoa would fall into the sea
triggering a series of devastating
tsunamis millions of people in the
surrounding area of Indonesia would be
at risk of death death if you lived in
Jakarta you'd want to find some very
high ground because a wave of over 37 M
tall would drench the capital and people
in coastal areas as far away as Hawaii
and South America would be on tsunami
watch as well now if flights weren't
already cancelled planes would start
falling out of the sky visibility would
be reduced to a minimum but the big
threat would come from the volcanic ash
clouds they can damage flight controls
and cause engines to
fail the eruption would produce an
enormous amount of dust and debris so
much that if it all fell onto one place
like New York City only the antenna of
the Empire State Building would be
peeking out Indonesia and other parts of
Southeast Asia and Australia would be
devastated by all the ash falling onto
their
Farmland many crops and livestock would
struggle to survive in this ash
contaminated
environment now believe it or not
something positive might come from all
this
destruction it could be a cure for
climate
change well at least for a little
while when Krakatoa exploded in 188 3 it
lowered the average global temperature
for several years plus all that fine
dust in the air would create some
stunning
views for the next year sunsets and
sunrises would take on a spectacular red
and orange glow and the Sun and the Moon
would appear greener than you've ever
seen them
before okay now that all these volcanoes
have exploded Ed what happens next a
volcanic
apocalypse how much damage are we
talking about
here What would life be like for the
survivors and what do you mean it gets
even worse than
lava this is what if and here's what
would happen if a volcanic apocalypse
happen
tomorrow brace yourself this may just be
the wor worst weather forecast you're
ever going to hear every volcano on
Earth active or dormant on land or under
the sea is ready to blow the lid off
this place you can expect to see plumes
of Ash lava bombs and Jet spurts on
every single continent and in every
single ocean but I know what you're
thinking you can take the heat right
well take a seat there Sparky it's going
to get a whole lot
worse if every volcano on Earth erupted
at once it would set off some high
magnitude
earthquakes this is because so many
volcanoes are located near the shifting
tectonic plates of the earth and while
the lava and earthquakes would certainly
do some major damage one of the biggest
blows we're going to face is the nasty
gases that spew out of
volcanoes clouds of gas G smoke and Ash
can travel in almost liquidlike motions
to anywhere in the world they could
smother the Earth in a matter of
minutes but let's say for a second you
managed to survive the initial
explosions well I've got two very
upsetting words for you volcanic
ash the volcanic ash would black out the
skies blocking any sunlight in the
process this would cause the temperature
on Earth to plummet without the Sun the
Earth's surface temperature would plunge
to 0° after the first week and then to -
66° by the end of the first year on the
bright side it's not an inferno of death
anymore to make matters worse no
sunlight means no plants which means no
food for Animals most animal species
would go extinct as the L of plants
would set off a mass extinction due to
its impact on the food
chain and don't hold your breath for the
stragglers you can expect acid rain to
take care of them this is because of
those volcanic gases we mentioned
earlier hydrochloric acid hydrogen
fluoride hydrogen sulfide and sulfur
dioxide would condense in the atmosphere
and they would fall to the Earth as rain
this would then contaminate any
freshwater Supply we had
left but what if we had some Fighters
still kicking What would life be like
for those living in the
aftermath well the economy isn't going
to do you any favors the volcanic
destruction would cause a complete
economic collapse every business and
bank would shut down you'd lose access
to credit and become instantly
unemployed unless you count being a
wasteland Survivor as your new
job it would be full-blown
postapocalyptic out there searching the
ash covered world for aquafers
containing fresh water venturing out
into the Wasteland for supplies and
living in heated underground
bunkers now while it is very possible
that volcanoes could set each other off
by being in close proximity the chances
of every volcano on Earth exploding at
once is highly
unlikely but it does make us think about
how quickly things can go
south what if we could prepare for
something like this what if we built the
world's deepest
bunker well that's a story for another
what
[Music]
if